bien qu'on soit un petit peu fort simple
bonsoir merci d'être un mois d'augmenter
de venir nous parler du tarp le fameux
ta fenêtre cet endroit sombre qui fait
la joie que journaliste
sensationnaliste et qui fait tellement d
information qu'est ce que c'est que le
dark de darnell sais pas ce que l'on
vous présente c'est tout à fait autre
chose
un hors-jeu grands départs d'éviter ce
qu'est un bar mais vous savez comme jeux
sur internet se vous êtes absolument pas
de ligne grâce à votre fameuse adresse
ip dont nous avait tellement entendu
parler une visite doute racines votre
fournisseur d'accès c'est parfaitement
ce que vous faites sur internet un arbre
c'est tout simplement un protocole
réseau qui va utiliser internet en
intégrant nativement des fonctions
d'anonymisation ça veut dire que si vous
êtes sur un bar vous pouvez allez sur
internet vous pouvez échanger des
fichiers vous pouvez aller sur certains
sites web etc des rames ceci sans être
identifié le cadre du terme darnets
aignan cette notion d'anonymat elle a
dix ans de l'internet ouvert quand vous
êtes sur internet
eh bien vous êtes abonné alors comment
ça marche je veux pas m'arrêter sur des
détails techniques parce qu'il présente
l'intérêt mais je voulais fixe
simplement le principe général pour la
simple raison que ça fait l'objet de
tellement de fantasmes qui est
maintenant de comprendre que le
fonctionnement au final elle a dit
penser quand vous êtes sur le client et
comme vous internet normal et bien vous
allez vous connecter directement au site
de votre quotidien préféré quand vous
passez dans la dernière cette connexion
il va être en direct va passer en faites
par un ensemble de relais entre mineurs
et grinçant système de chiffrement fait
en sorte que ces relais ne connaissent
que le prédécesseur et de suivre les
normes actuellement 20 hocine ensuite on
est sorti vous voyez ici de connaître
l'origine de l'inde l'origine de l'un
d'eux la connexion vous acteurs bardin
vous êtes censé être un ace cne tissu
sky et darnets ont su vendre évidemment
ça dépend beaucoup du dard tels que vous
utilisez ménages par les principales à
savoir le réseau tor top c'est de lui on
l'utilisateur grand jour
est-ce que je suis à l'abri de
l'espionnage quand je suis sur tom les
révélations snowden ont montré que oui
très largement en clair vous voyez ici
c'est simplement un extrait d'un
document de l'année celles qui étaient
publiés en l'occurrence parsemain ce
document montre que la jeunesse est
effectivement capable de désaliniser des
connexions sur top mais ces documents il
montre également la formule de l'homme
fidh
ce document il montre également que si
vous voulez des anonymisées une
déconnexion temps vous devez malgré la
puissance de l'année s'est régalé les
essais de très loin le première la
première organisation de surveillance
d'internet pour nom de traîtres m et
bien pas une greenpeace impuissante si
la nsf d'anonymiser des relations sur
tom elle doit pratiquer de manière
manuelle est relativement laborieux en
club foot vous êtes quelqu'un qui est
ciblé par une grande agence de
renseignement ou par une structure il ya
des moyens techniques avancées et
effectivement il est possible que on
vous identifie mais si c'est pas le cas
ce qui est quand même quatre immenses
majorité des gens quand vous êtes sur
internet à minimum quand nous
assure-t-on bruit vous bénéficie d'une
vraie écurie
l'internet en appelant en vous en
présente ici quelques-uns des plumes
défaut représentatif et des plus
importants mais des dards fait il en
existe des dizaines et des dizaines
évidemment tort avec ses deux millions
d'utilisateurs et de loin le leader thor
a une particularité
j'ai quelques temps vous permet à
l'envoi d'actionnaires
cachez ce fameux dark web ne vous parler
rapidement dans quelques minutes mais
non permet également d'accéder au web
ouverts de manière à mener vous êtes en
chine vous êtes en russie vous êtes dans
un pays qui interdit la connexion
atteint d'un grand média occidental pro
occidental si vous passez par tonne vous
allez pouvoir les yeux du monde sur le
site du washington post sur le site de
ce que vous voyez ici sans être repéré
par les autorités
c'est la raison pour laquelle tort est
de loin l'outil le plus utilisé mais il
y en avoir d'autres freenet faire un
petit peu de place en ce moment pour des
raisons difficultés d'utilisation et
fonctionne comme lg paris depuis
lunettes et tout un tas d'autres n'y a
pas un d'armes il ya tout un ensemble de
dark un cadre d'un ensemble de
protocoles qui vous permet d'aller sur
internet de communiquer d'échanger de
partager des fichiers de partager des
photos des châtaignes à un protocole
spécifique berman djadjé de manière
anonyme donc à la venue regarder
lorsque vous connaissez le temps de
dormir pendant de manière générale c'est
ce qu'on voit là le darnell selma
darnets et le mal parce que sur le tarn
puisque ronny est un ami où se déroule
naturellement du sources qui sont
extrêmement convaincant c'est
incontestable le fait qu' il existe sur
le carnet des activités en sol humant
abjecte est une réalité incontestable
je prends là quelques exemples
évidemment il ya les fameux supermarché
de nombreux dons de tous entendu parler
du rôle à l'époque deux alphabets
multiples supermarché de la drogue et
autres et d'ailleurs qui ont fleuri sur
la marque mettra sur le dark wave se
réciter les pouvoirs trouve évidemment
des stupéfiants rappelle quand même que
le principal fournisseur de solutions
dans un pays comme la france et
instagram deathmatch a tancé par ses
passes à elle reste pas moins que vous
allez trouver les solutions mais vous
n'avez trouvé également des armes vous
allez y trouver des choses assez
amusante c'est pas comme des cris de
changement d'identité vous pouvez
commander un kit de son identité pour
envoyer vos photos de les recevoir en
retour une carte d'identité un passeport
éventuellement de la fausse monnaie
c'est ce genre de choses que vous pouvez
effectivement obtenir de masques façon
simple comme si vous fonctionnez sur
amazon les grands enfants mais
fonctionne exactement comme amazon
insérés dans les têtes c'est à dire que
vous venez au fournisseur affilié et
puis ils prennent leurs commissions en
passant vous pouvez même y trouver même
si c'est un fake dans la mesure où
aujourd'hui on n'a jamais eu le droit de
réalisation et l'offre de services de
tueurs à gages contre les marques et
comme je les montre et
pour nominer de la maturité de ce type
d'environnement souhaite présenter ici
une publicité pour torche vous
connaissez peut-être prestashop près sa
chambre c'est un outil open source qui
permet à n'importe qui de monter son
magasin en ligne eh bien il existe la
même chose sur le dark wave c'est à dire
que l'on met à votre disposition
une sorte de magasin près paris n'avait
plus qu'à le paramétrer à mettre vos
1,20 m nos produits dans la vitrine
correspondant c'est à dire qu'il n'a pas
besoin d'être un technicien avance
d'ores et déjà vous pourrez acheter et
sort d'une boutique tout fait pour aller
sur le narb à la ruine sportivement en
ce sens le dard grèce m ce n'est pas
seule chose dont vous entendez parler de
manière à la fois parce que c'est assez
spectaculaire est beaucoup plus il est
beaucoup plus attrayant pour un journal
de titres et furent le tarn est qui est
le principal fournisseur de drogue sur
l'éventuel achat de prestations de
services d'un tueur à gages que de
titrer sur des sources qui sont beaucoup
plus profondes beaucoup plus serré
matin en fait c'est d'abord et avant
tout un outil au service des libertés
j'ai parlé de thor josé beaucoup parler
nos torts et notamment du darfour est
donc cette partie du web qui est sûre
temps où ce néron de toutes ses
activités et bien
le dire qu elle représente quelques
pourcents et ont gagné environ 5% de la
bande passante de temps 95 posant de la
bande passante de tordre est utilisé
pour une région que pour aller sur des
marchés illégaux que pour aller sur des
forums
extrêmement discutable et aux 95 % de la
bande passante de thor est utilisé pour
des activités qui n'ont rien à voir avec
l'arbre
alors pourquoi est ce que on peut
considérer que le mur est le remède d'un
outil au service des livres
et promoteur lennar et principaux
promoteurs du nord net ceux qui font le
plus haut le développement du drame
c'est par les grandes organisations
mafieuses c'est pas les grandes
organisations criminelles c'est d'abord
et avant tout les grandes organisations
du jour danis particulier de
journalistes d'investigation
une organisation comme reporters sans
frontières pour prendre l'exemple de la
france met à disposition de ses
adhérents ce qu'ils appellent un kit de
survie numérique le kit survie numérique
tv autres sont des fichiers le kit de
survie numérique ce n'est rien d'autre
qu'un ensemble d'outils pour accéder aux
d'arbres pourquoi
les journalistes d'un coeur des
journalistes d'investigation est compris
dans nos pays démocratiques
avec protéger nos sources vous avez
besoin vous protégez vous même vous
devez garantir la ressource le fait que
quoiqu'il se passe il sera impossible la
vannerie la publication de votre âme à
peine à remonter à lui que remonter un à
un
le tarn est en ce sens que c'est un
outil qui permet à ces grandes
associations de journalistes de donner à
leurs adhérents les moyens d'exercer
leur métier dans des conditions de
sécurité réseau mais
j'aime ici également mais thierry soumis
un succulent toi
le n'arrête est un outil au service de
la lutte contre les abus des puissants
wikileaks a révélé noir puisse penser
l'évolution de wikileaks au cours des
années des années récentes
wikileaks a dénoncé des faits qui
autrement n'auraient jamais pu être
dénoncés mais ça va beaucoup plus loin
les grands médias en un exemple nuage il
importe que nous allons trouver la bulle
sonnerait grands médias français met à
la disposition des populations des
outils de lips ce que rob sait rien
d'autre qu'un outil qui va utiliser de
l'arn sur le grès vous pouvez déposer de
l'information qui ensuite sont mises à
disposition du jourdain les fans
attendaient les paladins de peur les
luxes lise exceptée toutes ces fuites
qui nous ont permis de mettre en
évidence en l'occurrence et à lui des
pluies sans nom était possible qu'un
rhapso darknet qu'un mars coque
sa paroisse de cas uniquement parce que
les lanceurs d'alert suzanne est protégé
par l'existence d'un réseau anonymous a
en ce sens l'arrière est un outil au
service de la liberté d'information mais
c'est aussi une forme comme un outil au
service de la lutte contre les abus des
puissants
plus grave plus important
évidemment le damned est un outil au
service de la dissidence politique
vous êtes un dissident politique dans un
pays dictatorial répond vous avez besoin
nous protéger pour mener à bien votre
lui pour arriver à rassembler des
partenaires pour renforcer votre vous
avez besoin de communiquer de manière
anonyme en ce sens effectivement le tarn
est un outil au service
de la dissidence politique
je prends l'exemple ici d'un dindon
quelqu'un qui est devenu un mythe
évidemment marcel carné et exécutés par
le régime syrien mais qui a vite
dizaines et des dizaines d'autres
activistes sur internet si on peut être
arrêter parce que usa la capacité qu'ils
avaient à dissimuler leur action était
insuffisante le fait de disposer
d'outils anonymisant le fait de pouvoir
passer par le narbonne pour s'organiser
permet de lutter contre les abus
dictatoriaux l'instar des résidences
politique mais on peut aussi parler des
dissidents sociedad
qu'elle appelle distance et 1 c'est par
exemple le fait que dans un certain
nombre de pays d'afrique
l'homosexualité condamné en avant en
ouganda par exemple vous êtes
susceptible d'être condamné à une peine
de prison à vie
pourtant
si vous êtes homosexuel en afrique comme
dans n'importe quelle communauté vous
avez devant vous organisez vous avez
besoin d'échanger avec mon père vous
avez besoin de les changer pour
organiser un tel évènement tout
simplement pour former communauté les
nets sont des services à sont au service
de cette dissidence s'éteindra sedanais
ici un exemple qui vient en fait d'un
être toniox
grâce à vous pouvez vous organisez
pouvait finir votre une dissidence
société à l'abri du regard évidemment
des des services de sécurité
mais un drame beaucoup plaint c'est la
nuit contre la surveillance
depuis le 11 septembre les états unis
d'abord avec la haine aisés ont mis en
place un vaste système de surveillance
de man un système de surveillance de
m'installer dire que nous sommes tous
fourni vous de la polémique sur la mise
en place des fameuses boîtes noires en
forme ça donc c'est parti des états unis
mais c'est maintenant évidemment
généralisée ça veut dire que nous sommes
tous surveillés nous sommes surveillés
indirectement et c'est pas des gens en
train de vous regarder mais ça veut dire
tout simplement que l'ensemble de nos
activités sur internet sont susceptibles
d'être observés par des fermiers de
sécurité c'est un changement fondamental
dans l'histoire de l'homme c'est la
première fois dans l'histoire de
l'humanité qu'un gouvernement a la
possibilité de surveiller l'ensemble de
sa population
pour un service de renseignements épars
bien servi de réellement démocratique je
suis pas en train de parler d'une
quelconque concourt pour prendre le
poids pour un service de renseignements
un service de sécurité
le fait d'avoir une vue sur ce que fait
l'ensemble de sa population s'est
naturellement par eni ils font ça pour
notre sécurité au corps il s'agit pas là
de mettre en place un système de
contrôle de manière rabbani fier qu'on
fait à nous orienter il s'agit tout
simplement d'essayer d'assurer notre
sécurité
il n'en reste pas moins de lizac de
cette surveillance de masse nous mène à
une société qui est excessivement
d'inquiétant nous mêmes à une
organisation du guardian qui est
extrêmement perturbant on sait depuis
longtemps parce qu'elle est aux comptes
études qui ont été menées que quand on
se sait surveillé
on a tendance à modifier son
comportement si nous manière
éventuellement et souvent inconsciente
on a tendance à
transformer son comportement pour qu'il
tend à aller dans le sens de ce que l'on
pense que le surveillant souhait c'est
insidieux
cette intention mais c'est une réalité
et c'est cette réalité que nous sommes
en train de vivre depuis quelques années
qu'est-ce que ça tenait à dire que
progressivement larmes nous vivions dans
un environnement qui dit un
environnement relativement livre nous
nous dirigeons vers ce que deux
soukhoum ans et de rose ont appelé la
société contre au ton expression la plus
marquée est actuellement c'est
évidemment le système de crédit social
chinois qui passe beaucoup par le
contrôle sur internet si vous agissez
conformément aux souhaits de partie vous
gagnez des points si inversement vous
êtes étudiant vous perdez des points qui
vous gagnez des moindres révélé avant
table dans les transports dans les
hôpitaux il vous permet des points vous
êtes évidemment pénalisé ne pouvez plus
vous déplacer au moins qu'on déplace
à tout moment un gouvernement est
capable de vous dire oui toi tu est
conforme du peuvent faire ça pointe
n'est pas conforme ne peut pas faire ça
la société qui est en train de se mettre
en place penser que ceci restera
cantonnée à des pays comme la chine c
est le réel ce n'est pas tant c est à
dire qu'on va avoir un crédit social
similaire en france demain matin c'est
pas du tout ça simplement la tendance
insidieuse qui est actuellement engagée
c'est celle-là
on a vécu jusqu'à récemment dans ce
coeur les grands philosophes français
appelait la société discipline c'est à
dire que nous sommes punis quand une
trompe nous sommes 100 fermes la société
d'enfermement la fin
demain comme deleuze la marque il a noté
des lymphomes 80 le dos des régions à
une société de contrôle une société de
contrôle nous c'est à dire que nous
sommes libres mais d'où sort tout le
temps
contrôler nous sommes tout le temps sous
surveillance c'est très exactement ce
qui est en train ne se passe alors pour
reprendre ce que disait deleuze à
l'époque
l'important ce sera peut-être de trouver
des bagnoles de non communication des
interrupteurs pour échapper aux autres
au sein de cette société de contrôle nos
mains nos espaces de liberté dépend de
notre capacité
à créer bacchus le tarn c'est
précisément dans ces interrupteurs c'est
précisément l'une de ses bas qu elle en
ce sens et pas d'armes elle devrait
s'amarrer les biens friel devant bien
ici
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]